hey guys now how do you grow your beard
faster well as we're gonna talk about in
this video so let's get this very quick
if your first time here on my channel
I'm Daniel and welcome to D LM model
lifestyle if you haven't yet please
subscribe and click that notification
belt so you won't miss any of the next
videos no is it possible to grow your
beard faster well yes it is but there's
a couple of things that you need to
understand first everyone has different
genes so our beard start to grow at
different ages it can start growing at
your early teens your early 20s late
twenties and early thirties so you can't
really control the exact time when your
beer starts to grow because it's tied in
with your DNA just like the color of
your eyes the color of your hair and
your length as well but that being said
there are a few things that you can do
to make your hair grow faster so let's
start with the first one the first one
is exercise there's a huge link between
exercise and hair growth if you exercise
more it will increase your blood flow
and testosterone and it will help your
beard to grow faster
got exfoliate your skin if you never do
this then it's time to start because you
got to get rid of those dead skin cells
in the dirt in your pores if you do that
your face will look a lot clearer and
help your beard to grow better you got
to eat the right kind of food
look your beard is not gonna grow as
good as it can if you don't give it what
it needs so you gotta eat more healthy
fats and healthy protein so for example
eggs which are rich in protein and it is
a natural source of biotin spinach which
is rich in protein calcium magnesium and
potassium and all of which will help
your facial hair to grow better oh and
cinnamon now cinnamon is great because
it helps the flow of oxygen to your hair
follicles which helps your beard to grow
sweet potatoes because they are rich in
beta-carotene and you can also eat
oysters and livers
supplements if you take good supplements
like biotin and fish oil is gonna help
your beard to grow faster other good
options are iron beard and the fighter
beer now I'll add those for you Nvidia
description if you wanna check them up
now that Sepp is to stop shaving there's
a lot of people who believe this myth
and say hey if you shave every day your
beard is gonna start to grow faster it's
not true listen a good beard takes
patience so take a month let your beard
grow so if you can see what you have
next up is Minox Adele now you probably
heard of this before because it's famous
across the world for helping guys to
grow their hair especially for those
guys are those patchy beards to look
fuller but just you know not everybody
gets the same result some guy says yes
it works great help me to grow my hair
other guy says nah it's not really for
me also I got some side effects so you
got a do your own research on this one
and remember I'll add everything for in
the video description just to make it
easier for you to go and check them then
you got a reduce your stress
you've probably heard in some of my
other videos that stress can cause hair
loss and it's not just for your hair on
your head but also for your beard so you
got to start adopting healthier ways of
living and thinking to reduce your
stress
you can also get a beard transplant now
this is a little bit extreme so I
wouldn't really recommend it I just want
to give you all the options to create
good content on my channel but I don't
recommend this because I believe that
you should be content with the way that
you look you gotta accept your genes
even if you have a patchy beard or no
hair at all because that is what makes
you you and remember if you're still
young
everybody's beard starts to grow at a
different age so don't rush it
just relax and wait for it and remember
having a good beard doesn't make a man
more than your character a good
character makes you more manly and if
there's for some reason I don't know if
there's some reasons that you didn't
feel hundred percent happy or content
with the way that you look then check
out this video here and it's gonna help
god I'll see you there
cheers guys